Just to shake things up, let's get started on the right.
Here our start symbol is S and it goes to PQR and there actually aren't that many choices.
If we think about it, there are two strings in this grammar--PQR and PQ nothing.
So this doesn't look like a good bet because it doesn't produce PQQ, or P, or PR.
This is not a match. All right. What do we have over here?
Well, every string is going to have to start with lowercase p and then Q,
looks like I can have 0 or more Qs and then eventually we end with an R.
This looks pretty good because it matches the first string
and the string down here, but it doesn't get PQQ so I don't like this one.
How about this grammar in the middle that uses ABC instead of Senatus Populus Que Romany
in the name of the senate and the people of Rome--A, B and C?
Well, we have two choices for our start symbol that definitely complicates things,
but both of them start with a P--well that's convenient
since all five of our strings starts with a P.
Let's just go through the strings one at a time. Can I get P alone?
Yes. A goes to PB. B goes to nothing--so I can get that one. How about PQQ?
A goes to PB. B goes to Q and then Q again and then nothing. Yeah, I can get that one.
How about PR? A goes to PBC. B goes to nothing. C goes to R.
This is looking super promising. PQR--we use the first rule-PBC.
We'll gather up one Q and then we'll have an R. Great! PQQR. We use the first rule--PBC.
We'll go around this loop twice to get two Qs and then end with an R.